madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres monsieur le Président chers
collègues au moment où nous débattons de
la guerre en Ukraine je voulais aussi
adresser au nom de mon groupe et plus
largement je le sais notre soutien aux
femmes iraniennes et aux hommes engagés
à leur côté pour lutter contre une
effroyable dictature islamiste en Iran
la France
la France ne pourra
la France ne pourra rester forte que si
elle continue à incarner son humanisme
et défendre les droits de l'homme et des
libertés partout dans le monde menacé y
compris comme en Ukraine aux frontières
de l'Europe
depuis 222 jours le peuple ukrainien
résiste héroïquement à l'agression
unique de la Russie Poutine beaucoup
estimaient pourtant que le pays
tomberait en trois jours nourrit à plein
par la propagande russe renvoyant une
image de superpuissance de son armée de
ses dirigeants il n'en a rien été cette
résistance ukrainienne a évidemment un
coup humain d'abord effroyable en
Ukraine ou la Russie ça donne à des
massacres de civils et des crimes de
guerre tous les jours les dirigeants
russes devront rendre des comptes
la guerre est également bien évidemment
un coût économique et social l'Ukraine
voit une bonne partie de ces
infrastructures totalement détruites une
chute drastique de ces productions et
des millions de réfugiés internes
externes pour faire face à cette crise
que nous demande les Ukrainiens
outre des armes lourdes pour pouvoir se
défendre de l'aide humanitaire et de
l'accueil dans les meilleures conditions
possibles des auxiliés sur notre sol les
Ukrainiens nous demandent face à leur
sacrifices des programmes d'aide à long
terme pour la reconstruction l'emploi le
logement la santé c'est bien la moindre
des choses ils ont besoin de dons plutôt
que de près pour éviter de laisser une
dette insurmontable à un pays victime
d'une agression barbare
l'armée russe et maintenant sur le
reculoir elle enchaîne les défaites et
Poutine multiplient les provocations et
menaces si la guerre a des répercussions
économiques jusqu'en France et dans le
monde cela ne doit pas nous détourner de
nos engagements encore moins maintenant
la propagande russe a voulu instiller le
poison de la division en France et en
Europe elle a fait en retournant la
responsabilité du déclenchement de la
guerre et ses conséquences sur le temps
et sur les gouvernements européens aux
Français qui se posent encore des
questions légitimes rappelons que le
coupable du déclenchement de cette
guerre et de ses répercussions c'est la
Russie le Poutine et elle seule et que
l'Ukraine ne défend pas seulement son
territoire mais aussi le modèle
occidental démocratique que Poutine
désormais annonce vouloir détruire le
combat des Ukrainiens c'est aussi notre
combat
raison de plus de faire également notre
autocritique sur un certain aveuglement
d'un large spectre de notre classe
politique française oui il y a bien eu
un aveuglement d'une certaine extrême
gauche qui par réflexe anti-américain
n'a jamais voulu voir la menace que le
dictateur russe au discours
authentiquement fasciste faisait peser
sur les fondamentaux démocratiques
européen oui les propos de l'extrême
droite ont été troublants on se demande
toujours comment peut-elle à ce point se
lever dans les bras d'un dirigeant
citron à vouloir détruire le monde
occidental si ce n'est par accointance
idéologique j'espère que le soutien de
Poutine d'une certaine partie de notre
classe politique et maintenant
clairement derrière nous
des patriotes ou des pseudos
révolutionnaires qui se soumettent à une
puissance étrangère qu'elle farce sans
ce sans parler de tous ceux qui pour
quelques prébendes allez en pèlerinage à
Moscou espérons que cela servira de
leçon face à la Chine de plus en plus
agressive et particulièrement face à
Taïwan
aveuglement enfin teinté de naïveté
parfois des services de l'État
reconnaissons le ou de responsables
politiques de tout bord et au plus haut
niveau qui n'ont pas su ou n'ont pas
voulu voir le danger que représentait la
Russie de Poutine et de l'imminence
d'une invasion de l'Ukraine nous étions
pourtant prévenus par les précédents de
la Georgie en 2008 et de la Crimée en
par pitié n’appelons plus à ne pas
humilier la Russie alors que
d'effroyable massacre de civils ont lieu
en Ukraine
une fois encore si le diagnostic de la
nécessité de l'Europe de la défense et
le bon force est de constater que la
volonté manque pour avancer plus vite il
faut que l'Europe accélère car une fois
de plus cette guerre démontre que nous
ne pouvons pas nous passer de
l'intervention des États-Unis
Vladimir Poutine est dans une offensive
de propagande au long cours pour
déstabiliser nos sociétés en l'aidant en
s'aidant de notre dépendance énergétique
et des effets sur l'inflation il joue la
division de nos opinions publiques ne
cédons pas la pression russe et assez
relais en France continuons à livrer
davantage d'équipements militaires
affirmant que le soutien de l'Ukraine et
le soutien au foyer et aux entreprises
françaises sont compatibles et ne
doivent pas être opposés restons ferme
sur nos Fondements de solidarité de
liberté quelles leçons d'héroïsme et de
bravoure sont en train de nous donner
nos amis Ukrainiens à leur place
qu'aurions-nous faire vive l'Ukraine
libre pour toujours vive l'Europe
l'Europe de plus en plus fort et vive la
France
[Applaudissements]